So the best way to answer this is to use
pop. Pop's the only thing we've seen that actually removes
elements from a list and it also has the property
that it returns that element. If we do tocrawl.pop() that'll get
us the last element in the tocrawl list. Remove that
element from the list tocrawl. And assign that to the variable
page. One important point to note is because we're getting
the last element first. What we are implementing is what's called
a depth-first search and that means that as we crawl webpages,
If we had three links on the first page. Well, what's
going to happen is we are going to follow that last link. We're
going to add the links that we find there to the page.
Before getting to these links, well, we're going to follow this link,
right? That's going to be the last link that we added. We're
going to follow that, we're going to get to that page, and we're
going to follow the last link on that page. So, this is why
it's a depth-first search. We don't get to look at the second
link on the first page until we've followed all the links that
we can reach from the last link on the first page. If
our goal was to get a good corpus of the web quickly,
doing a depth-first search would probably not be the best way to
do it. And some of the questions at the end of your
homework, ask you to figure out ways to change the search order,
that will give us a better way of capturing content on the Web.
For now, we're going to be happy, and with the
test site, it's enough to do a depth-first search. If
we can complete our search, no matter what order we
follow, we'll always find the same set of pages. If
we aren't able to complete the search, and with a
real web crawler, there's far too many pages to wait
until we find them all to return a result, then
the order that we do the pages matters a lot.